todo intenso en torno a las 8 de la
mañana comenzó con un chile dios en los
alrededores del palacio presidencial en
el centro de la capital conakry donde
estaba el jefe de estado guineano alpha
condé unas horas más tarde se difundió
en las redes sociales una declaración de
mamá y dumbría jefe del grupo de fuerzas
especiales una unidad de élite del
ejército guineano en este vídeo el que
es diseñado ahora como el hombre fuerte
del país afirma haber capturado al
presidente alpha condé de sobre las
instituciones y serán las fronteras más
tardes de más tarde los golpistas
hicieron una declaración en la
televisión nacional guineana para
reiterar estas afirmaciones en conakry
la situación sigue siendo muy tensa y
confusa los habitantes afirman haber
visto a muchos soldados pidiéndoles que
no salgan de sus casas a esta crisis
política se produce tras la disputada
elecciones el pasado mes de octubre de
alpha condé que ha estado al frente del
país durante más de diez años este es 13
mandatos del presidente guineano fue muy
criticada por la oposición y provocó una
crisis post-electoral qué causa la
muerte de más de decenas de personas